Hi, I'm Alice Boxhall a software
engineer on the Google Chrome
accessibility team.
And I'm Rob Dodson,
a developer advocate for Chrome.
We can help you understand how you
can make your websites accessible and
usable for everyone.
We're also working with our
friend Mike from Udacity.
>> I'm Mike Wales,
a program manager here at Udacity.
I'll be helping you through exercises,
so
you can make sure your applications
are accessible to everyone.
>> Accessibility is a pain to spell.
So we often shorten it a little why, but
it doesn't have to be a pain to work on.
We'll show you how you can get some easy
wins to help improve access ability with
minimal if it.
How you can use what's built into
HTML to create more accessible and
robust interfaces.
Add some advanced techniques for
creating really polished
accessible experiences.
>> You'll also see as we go that a great
deal of this work will help you create
interfaces which are more delightful and
easy to use for really everyone.
In fact, I think a lot of developers
have only a pretty hazy understanding of
what accessibility means, something
to do with government contracts and
checklists and screen readers.
And there are plenty of
misconceptions floating around,
like a lot of developers feel that
addressing accessibility is going to
force them to choose between creating a
delightful and attractive experience and
taking a box saying that
their site is accessible.
So, what do we mean by accessibility and
really like what are we
here to learn about?
>> Well, broadly speaking when
we say a site to be accessible,
we're saying that the site's content
to be available to everyone.
And functionality can
be operated by anyone.
Literally that everyone
should be able to access it.
When it comes to developing sites
which are accessible by everyone,
we need to be a bit more specific.
>> As developers, it's easy to fall into
the trap of assuming that all users can
see and
use a pointer interface like a mouse or
a touch screen and experience your
application the same way that you do.
And this can lead to creating
an experience which might work well for
a narrow range of people, but creates
issues for anyone outside of that range.
>> Accessibility in that case prefers
the experience of users who might be
outside of that narrow range.
And who might access or
experience things differently to the way
the person we picture as
a typical user would.
Specifically, concerned users who are
experiencing some type of impairment or
disability and I say experiencing
that because it makes absolutely no
difference whether that impairment is
situational, temporary or permanent.
>> So with that in mind, let's explore
what happens when we actually do take
an inaccessible site and
make it more accessible.